hey guys Pete here today I'm going to
take another look at the Game of Thrones
trailers but this time I'm going to tie
all the images together with all the
filming spoilers we were following last
year so this is your spoiler warning
this is basically a celebration of
spoilers and extravaganza of them to be
precise so if you don't want to know
what's going to be happening in Game of
Thrones Season 7 please stop watching
now now this doesn't include leaks I
threw all of my spoiler and filming
coverage I stayed away from the leaks
that dropped on reddit I mean what's fun
for me about the theme of set photos and
knowing where the actors are and stuff
is - figuring it out part you know like
piecing it all together the leak just
gives us answers rather than any type of
journey and that's pretty boring to me
at the end of the day so I'd rather not
know but I really like to speculate
about what we see if you're not familiar
with my channel I put out spoiler videos
last year on a weekly basis while the
season 7 filming was going on if you
have never seen any of those you should
check out my spoilers playlist because
there's a ton of them in fact there are
so many of them I'm not going to be able
to do them all in this video but if
there's good response to this I will
keep adding part so this will just be a
part one because I don't want to make it
super long alright so I went through
using the mashup trailer to pull
screenshots in order to give me some
direction the first image we see in this
is your owns new fleet arriving at
King's Landing we're going to talk more
about this and his arrival later because
there's other photos related to that but
there's not much to say about this image
since we didn't really have anything as
far as filming pictures go related to it
after that we got a shot a grey worm in
a small boat where he's looking at a
small cave on the shore we know from
shooting locations that this is outside
of Casterly Rock
this was initially a surprise when the
actor who plays grey worm showed up in
this location and as the days of
shooting progressed we were able to put
together that the unsullied were
attacking the Lannisters at home
Tyrion once was in charge of the sewers
we know that from previous episodes
and he has some knowledge that he would
have to grey worm that would help him
get inside undetected after that we saw
Jaime walking along the castle wall that
is just a brief glimpse in the trailers
this is an event that we had a lot of
information about we found out this is
Highgarden the castle of house Tyrell
and the Jaime and Bronn ended up taking
it over for House Lannister of course
these two houses had once been on the
same side if you overlook the fact that
they poisoned King Joffrey
so that Margaery wouldn't have to stay
married to him but of course at the end
of season six we saw that they had
joined with Daenerys after Cersei
decided to blow up the Sept with all of
their remaining family members inside
other than the Queen of thorns we'll
talk more about that whole situation
later but as you can see from these SEC
photos the Lannisters came in and they
took over Highgarden which was a castle
we hadn't seen in previous seasons the
next image in this mashed-up trailer is
Damaris arriving at the gates of
Dragonstone there were so many images of
this some of which were released
officially by HBO so I'm not going to
get too much into that here her arrival
I will put a link up at the top here for
the mega spoilers video that I put out
that has a lot of the information about
what we were seeing as we knew that they
were first shooting at Dragonstone it's
one of really just the one of those is
called the mega spoilers because there
is it lives up to its name let's say
that then we see the unsullied who
entered through the sewer that they made
it actually inside and were able to let
their brothers inside the gates of
Casterly Rock there were a lot of photos
from around this location but nearly
none from inside like we didn't see them
filming any of these battle scenes so we
got indications that you know the
unsullied were there and that there were
plenty of Lannister soldiers in costume
getting taken to the set but the big
thing that stood out at the time was
that there were no Dothraki spottings
like we had at the Dragonstone scenes
this goes into the next image in the
trailer which was this Dothraki charge
and the filming of those scenes
filled in a lot of the blanks as to what
the major battles would be while they
were shooting there this was we got some
of the most exciting battle related
images of the year for sure through
those we realized that the Dothraki were
attacking the Lannister caravan of
supplies that they were bringing back
from Highgarden
originally it was unclear who was
attacking who because randyll Tarly and
the new cast member that we found out
about Tom Harper which he's replacing
the old dick and Tarly he's the actor
who is now dick and Tarly they were in
those shots as well
but after weeks of filming there we
realized that it was an attack on the
caravan which Jaime and Bronn were
bringing back from Highgarden to King's
Landing and then the tarly's must have
shown up to help support the crown it
also became clear that Daenerys wasn't
there in the beginning of the battle
with drogon the Dothraki moved on the
caravan first and then she ended up
coming in and teams that we see that
also most likely ties to her leaving
Dragonstone what we see Tyrion looking
up and you know he basically knows there
that she's going to attack an army that
his brothers leaving the game of thrones
crew shot here for weeks so we had tons
of different photos from different
photographers who shot from a really
long distance but still managed some
really awesome pictures for us to fiend
over in the past we saw a lot of them a
lot of formation shots early with some
green-screen sightings and some open
spots in there where it looked like
they're probably going to bring some
dragon stuff in but then Emilia Clarke
actually showed up in this part of Spain
and after that we got photos that were
pretty exciting after that it definitely
became clear that drug ons presence
changed everything
we got great shots of how this battle
unfolded way too many to show here but
I'll put a link here in the top again
where you can check them out after
they're definitely amazing this battle
has become referred to as the field of
fire part 2 which relates to Aegon's
conquest King lore in the first of the
lannister family and the king of the
to that time we're attempting to turn
the Targaryen forces around after that
you know Aegon had already destroyed the
Riverlands and so so on so they had a
pretty good battle plan and they they
attacked but Aegon and his sister wives
Visenya and Rainey's turned the battle
their way by getting on their dragons
and basically burning everyone alive the
next big interesting shot in this
trailer is the clip of Melisandre
looking over Dragonstone there were some
red woman sightings on the set while
they were filming in this region but
since Chris Van Houten was never
confirmed to be in Spain like every
other actor that we saw and scenes we
weren't sure that this would actually
happen like we knew Kimbra was not
supposed to return for this but there
was just no conclusive evidence that the
person in the red outfit was actually
Melisandre so her showing up in the
trailer was super exciting for that
reason but honestly don't know how much
of any of this fits together like if she
did shoot a lot of shots they must have
all been indoors in the studios because
she wasn't a constant presence at any of
the locations the fact that she's
looking over from a distance in the
trailer doesn't help anything either
because we can't say that she definitely
shot scenes with Daenerys or Jon Snow
but all this oldest relates to the time
when they were filming Jon's trip to
dragonstone and you know who knows how
Jon would react he may not be as harsh
as he was since he's not in the North
anymore but we know he travels with
Davos so he's definitely not changed his
mind about how he feels about the red
woman since I mentioned Jon traveling
south let's take a closer look at this
image of Daenerys she's all dressed up
and turns it as if she's being presented
with the guest or something along those
lines before when they were actually
working on season seven we saw a video
of this exact same thing I think it's
the exact same scene but it was a video
of them shooting it like you know
someone was a camera was filming the
film crew making the scene the video
showed Jon Snow descend the stairs to
approach Daenerys who was waiting at the
bottom
looking over the water from the landing
on the huge outdoor set of stairs that
we see this is the first confirmation
that these two would actually meet in
person and that made for an amazing day
for all of us spoiler fanatics I'll put
a link here to that video to is a really
short one but it was you know it's fun I
just watched it before I was making this
and it's fun to think about a time when
we weren't sure that these two were
actually going to meet up but that we'll
jump ahead to this image which we saw
before the actual meetup that came out
first we learned the kid Harrington was
in town prior to his showing up on the
set but this image sealed the deal when
it came out we saw John and Davos
talking with each other like you see in
the trailer but we found out because we
had to bit the whole scene to see that
they're actually Dothraki right there
behind them and we know now that they're
getting permitted to approach the castle
where they were summoned by the Queen or
whatever you know that we know that
they're going to visit through other
filming news we know that this has to
happen after the stuff we see with John
at the Great Hall and Winterfell and
before all the stuff that we've seen
with him running around north of the
wall it's easy enough to speculate that
John addresses the northern forces at
Winterfell about the white Walker threat
and then get someone to Dragonstone
after Danny gets settled there since he
knows he needs all the help he can get
it's not surprising that he would go
also we know that stan has told him in
the past that there was plenty of
dragonglass around Dragonstone which
would give him some extra incentive i
mentioned this in my non spoilers
trailer breakdown because they pretty
much lay it out if you know what to look
for anyways we had an abundance of
images from these days of shooting to
the point that you could almost forget
that most of these characters spent the
entire series up to this point
never interacting with each other we got
so much stuff to that I'm gonna end this
here and what it looks like would be the
the right thing would be to I will talk
about John going north what we know
about that in the future video we'll
talk about what we know happens up at
Winterfell and then there's two other
battles to talk about
and Kings Landing stuff and the King's
Landing stuff is pretty darn interesting
because we had a lot of information
about when they were shooting the season
finale so let me know in the comments if
you want to see more please like the
video if you enjoyed it make sure you go
and subscribe to my channel I'll be
doing episode breakdowns once the season
starts next week I'll probably do
trailer breakdowns and some Theory
videos in there if stuff comes up that
would be interesting to cover make sure
you check out that spoilers playlist if
you want to get some more of this stuff
and thanks for watching I will talk to
you soon